I've been drinking five pounds of juiced carrots per day, so five pounds of carrots
juiced per day for two months now since the diagnosis of metastatic breast cancer.
Sort of natural chemotherapy, do you agree?
So yeah, juicing carrots is at a natural chemotherapy.
While juicing carrots can be a good source of nutrition, is that a natural chemotherapy?
No, I wouldn't agree with that. It's good source of good solid nutrition, which is beneficial
for your immune system. The negative thing about juicing carrots is that it does have a lot
of glucose in it and it can raise your glucose levels. Help your cancer is really driven
through glycolysis that it can be a wrong thing to do. But if juicing carrots over the
course of the last two months and your cancer hasn't grown, then I wouldn't be so concerned
about that. Juicing carrots also has, juicing anything also has some negative things that the juicing
people don't talk about, is that that's all wrong. Well, they talk about that as positive
because since it's all raw nutrition, then it has all the enzymes in it. You haven't cooked it and
ruined it and destroyed all the nutrition in it. But I just don't buy that. So if you're juicing,
you're basically pre-digesting things. So you're breaking things down to, you know, very small size,
that molecular size, but very small size. So it's easier for you to digest. So you're pre-digesting
it, but you still have to absorb those things. That means you still need enzymes secreted by your
pancreas in enough of a hefty dose in order for you to be able to break it down to molecular size
for you to absorb that. And as we age, we end up with less of those. Even if you're taking oral
enzymes, you're taking an exogenous enzyme capsule. You can still have some issues with digesting
raw foods. So people go on a raw food diet thinking that that's the best because they listen to
crisp work or something like that. And they're over 30 years old and they're taking their juicing,
you know, 10 glasses of juicity. And they're getting gut issues and things like that because they're not
really absorbing very well. And so even if it's better nutrition because you're juicing, if you're
not absorbing it, you're just deposited into the toilet. So it's going through this tube called your
intestinal tract and it's going right into the toilet. You're not getting the nutrition out of it
that you really should. That in fact, there's a diet called the gaps diet. So when people are really
ill, especially when they have bad gut issues from food sensitivities and all sorts of things like
that, which can't end up leading to cancer, which can people may be listening to this have been
into that category, the gaps diet, you're not taking anything raw. You're basically making soup
out of everything. So you're making a soup out of your vegetables. You're cooking it all day long
and it's it's pre-digesting in itself. And the juicing proud will go, oh, you're killing the enzymes,
enzymes aren't destroyed by that. You're still going to get the benefit out of the nutrients.
And you're breaking down the nutrients into a particle size that is pre-digested just like juicing.
And it's going to be a lot easier on your body and on your gut to be able to absorb those things.
You're not throwing away all the vitamins in the carrots because you're drinking the soup. You're
eating the broth, too. So I don't fall into the category that juiced is the right thing to do
for everyone. Now understand, if your if your cancer is a fed medley off of glycolysis and you're
able to tolerate juice like the taste of it and you're absorbing a lot of it and it's doing well,
for you, I'm not against it. But I'm not a person that thinks that you should be going on a
raw food diet in order to heal your cancer. I think any of those diets like that can be wrong for a lot
of people. Also, I just received my genetic report and there is a beta-carotene gene, the BCMO gene,
this person's talking about. The BCMO gene is a gene that those genes, what they do is help make an
enzyme to break down vitamin A. And what a person has a lot of BCMO gene defects, they don't break
down vitamin A and don't utilize vitamin A. So they actually need to take, it may be a good thing
to take more vitamin A. So if you're juicing carrots, you're getting beta-carotene from the carrots.
So that is the right thing to do. So, you know, for just based upon that gene,
eating more carrots would be the right thing to do. So, for that gene defect, supporting it with
increasing your vitamin A through food, aka carrots is the right thing to do.